verdez bon alors moi j'ai souvent été
trompés mais j'ai eu la chance à chaque
fois de connaître souvent ça s'est passé
devant moi donc j'ai connu les gens
le respect c'est le respect c'est pas
beau la chaîne ne s'était vraiment pas
de bol c'était pas voulu et une fois
j'ai su que c'était dans ma voiture et
c'était une star je peux pas donner le
nom et est donc dans une star encore
star mondiale mais je peux pas venir non
un nom mais n'a jamais cessé c'est une
star des c'est une star bon je vais le
des worlds apart je voulais me voir
on attend le groupe ne peut pas donner
le nom parce que il tout se passe bien
et tout ça pas steve on s'est
réconciliés
give you might heures
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
auteur des worlds apart et la mc2 avec
sa mère alors
oui avec votre main dans la main je
l'avais surpris et tout ça mais est donc
comme ils pouvaient pas sortir c'est une
grande victoire des bulls a pas
déjà sur la terre battue
du court donc il le dit il l'a dit on
sait qui c'est un mariage non j'ai pas
dit le nom
et une chaussure
4% et donc du coup même l'argent sur
trois comme il pouvait
vous pourriez être surpris comme commis
pouvait pas comme ils pouvaient pas
sortir dans la rue il se cachait dans le
coffre de ma voiture ce soir arnaud à la
fin il sortait et à ta meuf utilisé je
te donne
[Rires]
c'est un trait et doit on m'a alors j'ai
souvent été trompés ouais non non c'est
un des quatre on dira pas qui c'est
parce qu'en plus je les adore un cd peña
moi aussi maintenant c'est des potes et
donc sur la chanson toi et à 0
franchement ça va non je peux pas dire
et donc parce que j'ai souvent été
trompés mais souvent par des stars ça
fait un peu passer la pilule du cou
enserré outils d'autres avant nous dire
en quoi un immense joueur de foot un des
plus grands noms un immense acteur
français un des mails grand ah ouais
ouais ouais qui appelait à la maison et
tout mais je décrochais idiot
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
le coup de pression à quoi et on peut
accroître acteurs français immense
blaquart au dessus ici on savoure envie
toujours dit non mais je pense que vous
rêveriez un jour je les adore
vous l'adorez puis c'est un symbole un
ami de bernard non
merci dit non je peux pas je paie là je
suis ami avec tout le monde
autour des salaires là dessus mais ma
toile était mais bon c'était pas
totalement pas tout est alors un jour un
jour et que l'a fait lors des trois
victoires ils croient qu'ils ne devaient
pas être la maman ma copine de l'époque
qui les crocs lui qui est et lui dit il
lui dit alors tu as fais tes valises
pour le mexique didier pitcho direct il
dit ça et
ils sont partis ensemble au mexique il
invitait sur un tournage au mexique
c'est un mec qui a tourné au mexique on
avait déjà
j'arrête là et donc je peux vous donner
avant qu'une tête
[Rires]
donc je dis alors canal et chanteur
défunt le gars des excuses moi je me
suis je me suis vengé parce que donc
elle le cache est dans la voiture pour
sortir dans le coffre de la voiture
gemma vous savez ce qu'il allait tout le
temps donc ça avec tous les mardis ou
mercredis soirs deux soirs par semaine
ils venaient de loin ils allaient dans
le coffre de la voiture eh ben j'ai fait
pipi dans le coffre de la voiture
on est d'accord qu'on applaudit kerry a
raison on applaudit avec la piscine
[Rires]
j'adore n'était pas mon toujours été
courtisé ouais ouais c'est fou non mes
scénarios pipi c'est bête mais pis ça
sèche moi j'aurais fait l'autre
[Applaudissements]
supportable un supporter a en tout cas
jean merci pour vos histoires qui ont
fait du bien à nos invités
seront présents mais c'est vrai j'aime
rigoler c'est fou c'est donc un lieu
qu'il y ait eu quoi d'autre à chaumont
bat ça suffit là ils en seraient
immenses offre avec des ward a pas un
mec des worlds apart ya peut-être une
autre star du rock'n'roll mais je peux
pas de les racheter du rock'n'roll
[Rires]
était pas sûr de la star du rock n roll
jacques dahm idée parce qu'en fait que
ce plan b au pied de chez moi et j'avais
vu sortir de chez moi donc d'aller là
bas c'est sûr qu'il fait pas de concert
à la maison
non mais c'est sûr on mettait
tous bien m'avait pas dit creamer des
trials fort bon tu veux pas bien alors
deschamps il est comme un roquet
[Applaudissements]
et
d'ailleurs
des films drôles ou des films tristes il
a fait tout il a fait de tout mais
plutôt plus tôt christophe mathy côté
des policiers grecs aux charlots si
c'est ça il a trouvé moi aussi j'ai
trouvé un tournant si il était avec des
femmes très belle aussi dans sa vie les
deux oui ah oui non ah oui je suis papa
dire comment je peux pas dire le nom
demandez rien de long et qui faisait
leur demande
[Rires]
on sait déjà que son ex était bipolaire
grande époque et une paire d'heures non
mais sans déconner tu passes de la laddh
de loi ferait découlent
j'adore jouer en équipe de jouer en
équipe de france
et jouer en équipe de france où il joue
toujours joué de génération platini
platini est bon signe il était un
attaquant ouais non mais je parle pas il
votre femme je pense
[Applaudissements]